like the Russell Brand
you're like yeah you remind me of him a
little bit for our audience never heard
this term I Oscar what is this in
Ayahuasca is a DMT derived plant
it's a DMT derivative it's sort of the
liquid form of DMT usually the people
psychedelics and new ageism and the toad
that you're talking about Mike Mike
Tyson yeah he sort of popularized these
are all DMT derivatives the term I'm not
religious I'm spiritual today right
usually fall into I mean to get to the
whole gen aspect you're talking about
[Applause]
this is our religion Islam Islam this is
show
[Music]
assalamualaikum
Alex Abdullah
you got the uh nice to meet you too you
got quite a story quite a journey okay
you come from a Puerto Rican background
your father is also from the Humboldt
Park area in Chicago right your mother
and father didn't really practice much
religion
you took off you experimented a little
bit with uh more psychedelics more
psychedelic spiritual Pathways yeah but
you as we were talking earlier you
looked into
yes many different like almost all the
religions that were out there huh yes
yeah but you ended up with the um
this uh kind of like the Russell Brand
you're like yeah you remind me of him a
little bit Yeah Russell this new age uh
they call monism yeah yeah can you tell
us about that how did you go from your
parents who traditionally Puerto Ricans
Hispanic people are more Catholic right
right right right so tell us about the
early years they try to teach you
anything about Jesus and then how did
you end up experimenting with the DMT is
it called you know the psychedelics and
new ageism and all the other stuff that
goes along with it right
and I'm so excited so grateful to Allah
to be standing right here at the dean
center that is being established in
Tampa by brother Eddie from the dincha
we are so excited that he shows in Tampa
to be this Hub and Center for dawa not
just locally alhamdulillah where we can
host seminars programs dawa activities
there's enough space for a school
gymnasium Masala and a studio that can
inshallah reach people globally to share
the beauty of Islam we're so excited to
have this established here locally in
Tampa and I want to encourage you all do
what you can to help complete this
project and make it a reality and I
invite you all to join me in supporting
the Center of America for all of us to
share the beauty of the Deen with all
Humanity
[Music]
foreign
when I was very young I grew up in a
very secular single parent household uh
I grew up with my mother my parents were
divorced so I didn't really have a
relationship with my father until I was
about 20. I had a relationship with my
father's parents my grandparents and
they were a Christian but uh not very
practicing not really in the church
every weekend a very sort of superficial
Christian I never went through any of
the rituals or anything and like I said
growing up with a secular mother she
took me to church maybe a few times when
I was eight or nine but I think she was
very spiritually conflicted herself she
had a lot of worldly sort of
preoccupations why do you think she took
you to the church if she wasn't going
regularly herself herself she was more
on a secular I can count on one hand how
many times I've been in the church again
I think she was just trying to search
for things herself I think but her own
sort of worldly responsibility
responsibilities and preoccupation sort
of took over and she never really became
religious in any sort of sense but those
experiences were weren't very
significant on me I always sort of had
this sort of Western modern view of
religion which was one of skepticism and
cynicism sort of viewed religion as a an
institution which sought to oversimplify
and you know boil down the complexity
and the Mystery of being into a few
ideological positions that benefited a
few at the top of a social hierarchy
that it provided but of course I I
developed this understanding over time
and had a much more nuanced view who
taught you this understanding because
we're taught things these things are
kind of nurtured they're fed to us right
I think being a kid a child of the
internet generation there's a lot more
autodidacts a lot more self-taught
people who just kind of aren't given
much guidance in their own personal
lives by their family or friends and
they sort of seek you know wisdom
through the internet which can be a very
dangerous thing yeah that's how you know
you end up with things like new age
spirituality and the sort of
proliferation of these ideas
when the guidance isn't in the home or
isn't in the you know immediate
environment you're going to seek it
somewhere how old were you at that time
when I was when you were a so-called
figuring it out what religion is and who
God is right right I would say I didn't
really think very deeply about religion
and spirituality until much later in
life so about 15 or 16 certain things
started to happen that were hard to
ignore yeah it was always very like
politically and intellectually inclined
so I saw the the political and the
cultural situation kind of take a turn
for the worse yeah
um
certain things you know in that time
were happening I felt like the mental
health of my peers had really taken a
dip
uh certain things I mean I just refuse
to continue on this trajectory that I
had been told you know to seek higher
education for the purpose of a better
job when in my view it seemed like the
higher education institutions were
largely to blame for the intellectual
decline of the society a lot of my
friends were going off to college and
university and returning with extreme
ideological viewpoints that they didn't
have before attending uh their their
critical thinking and logical reasoning
skills seemed to have diminished and
that you know like we were saying That's
of course not the reason you go to
pursue education you go to get smarter
not to yeah you know so there you can
see they were getting injected with some
other stuff right right right
ideology that has kind of become the
norm nowadays yeah at least in my age
group have you heard this term wokism of
course yes what does that mean for like
the modern uh person I would never how
would you define it we hear this term
right right it's um it's a sort of vague
term for a sort of political correctness
that's become very popular wokism is
more associated with the liberal
Tendencies of the political sphere right
now
someone who's woke is gonna
end up on the Left End of the spectrum
on most ideas
but also be a little bit more vehement
about
again political correctness and things
of that nature yeah is this uh does that
fall into like the whole pronouns
someone really would fit that right
right that's more extreme end of what
people would call woke yeah sort of the
the gender ideology stuff
um the pronouns transgenderism
abortion a lot of these different ideas
I'm learning I'm learning all these uh a
lot of terms a lot of these terms and um
you are somebody who went towards this
this way of life of of experimenting
with the different plants and
psychedelics how did you end up taking a
road down in this direction well it
always felt very um connected to my
fitra my natural disposition I wouldn't
have articulated it like that before I
probably would have said something like
intuition yeah but um I always felt even
though I came from a materialist
background I always felt that there was
something more to the world
um
it wasn't until you know like I said
around the late high school years when I
started to see these things sort of
happen and it uh forced me to to explore
a little bit more and look into things
that I hadn't previously thought about I
never really thought in terms of purpose
or meaning and um around the age of 17 I
started to not get along too well with
my mother like I said from a single
parent household so I went to go live
with my grandparents and I graduated
from high school about six months early
or so so that kind of gave me some time
to uh
figure out what the new sort of Life
Path would be because I was very lost at
that time and I sort of locked myself in
a room in my grandparents house and
became very sort of creative and
introspective I read a lot of material
that uh probably went over my head
probably didn't retain much is very very
above my level but it definitely
influenced me whether it was Dostoevsky
Nietzsche
um
schopenhauer
Camus the psychoanalytics like Union
Freud
all of these things sort of allowed me
to develop my own understanding of the
world yeah and most importantly acquire
my own sort of self-motivation and this
all kind of led me into what you're
talking about the the I became very
interested in ethnobotany
ethnopharmacology and the whole
psychedelic counter-culturalist
movements of the 1960s and 1970s is that
almost like a just a religion of itself
uh certainly not it's not it's it's like
an anti-religion it's uh it sees itself
as the sort of counterpart to that I
started to read people like Terence
McKenna uh merchia liad
um uh
a lot of these sort of thinkers that
were Again part of this
counter-culturalist movement uh which
you know the 1950s coming out of the
1950s which were very traditional sort
of Christian time in America yeah you
have these sort of new age thinkers that
start to integrate psychedelics into
their lives and uh
you know from the from the RAM dasas and
the later you know the Tim learys in the
90s and all that sort of movement and
how how long did you partake in this
this type of Lifestyle um well I'm only
23 now uh it's kind of hard to believe
when I look back that I've had so many
experiences but I really think a law has
afforded me a lot of these uh things and
allowed me to share these experiences
with others so that they may benefit and
um
alhamdulillah I think protected me from
a lot of things that I could have fallen
victim to do people who use the term I'm
not religious I'm spiritual today
usually fall into somebody's couches yes
absolutely actually if you look at
statistics in the UK right now that's
the majority of people
um it's something like I don't want to
say any false statistics but I believe
it's something like uh 88 of people who
fall into that category would say that
they while they don't believe in a
religion they believe in something
higher they believe in in some sort of
spiritual aspect to the world and I
think that's the sort of uh indicative
of the failure of modern science to
provide people with a sort of meaningful
system of ideas that they can provide to
their lives I knew a person who
went to one of these
where they were passing around some of
these psychedelics and she narrates the
story if I remember correctly that this
was kind of something that was uh it
wasn't something that you have to know
someone get invited and then you have
this private group of so many people and
then they were doing some kind of
some kind of uh rituals and then he he
said that he started it seemed like they
were calling on some Spirits or he felt
he saw Spirit he he felt from that he
was affected to this day that he would
have nightmares and whatnot because when
he connects it back
uh to what he knows now about the gin
and about Islam right he felt like they
were calling on the Gin they were doing
some very weird stuff and then whatever
he had inhaled or taken or smoked
whatever that just also like took his
senses and everything to a whole
different level and right and uh is this
something similar to what uh yeah of
course there's a sort of um I definitely
went down I was very skeptical of
exactly everything you're talking about
what is this when I'm painting this
picture what what is that uh yeah bring
to mind when many of the new age sort of
uh movements that incorporate
psychedelics into their uh sort of
practice they're they're all very
different but they're sort of
amalgamation of all these different
religious traditions and I think when
someone says that they're uh
uh spiritual but not religious yeah
they're trying to imply that they've
been unable to apply a systematic
philosophical framework of reason to
their day-to-day lives yeah and this to
me seems to be a trivialization of what
religion is it's not a list of
philosophical beliefs that you can sort
of adopt or exclude uh yeah it's it's uh
you have to take the whole package for
itself how long were you a part of this
uh this did was there um
any any certain things like what was the
typical day like for you you mentioned
something about being on a farm for some
time yeah yeah I lived on an Ayahuasca
farm for a little while yes for our
audience never heard this term I Oscar
what is this in
Ayahuasca is a uh DMT derived plant that
a farm that actually derives this plant
now right well they were they had gotten
teachings from the Amazon from actual
shamans and Amazon they brought the
plant back with them they were
cultivating it it's um it's a DMT
derivative sort of the liquid form of
DMT usually the people the most popular
version of DMT in America would be like
sort of free based powder version yeah
but uh they also had the the toad that
you're talking about the Mike Tyson Mike
Tyson yeah he sort of popularized these
are all DMT derivatives uh psilocybin is
also very similar to DMT sort of one
molecular
strain off
you know they all have similar
properties definitely different I mean
to get to the whole gin aspect you're
talking about there's a sort of uh if
you look on the different trip reports
and the the different literature that's
been compiled over time about these
things there's a clear personality that
can be seen with each psychedelic people
describe their Ayahuasca trips as a lot
more feminine like a a motherly sort of
spirit that shows you child rearing in
nature and things like that a lot more
feminine whereas psilocybin mushrooms is
a lot more Spacey tends to be more
masculine a lot more alien outer space
based yeah this is all sort of vague
descriptions but as you start to sort of
compile all of the reports that people
have you start to see commonalities and
I think there's a lot of uh overlap here
with the Islamic concept of Jinn tell me
what were there any kind of okay you do
that and there are any kind of rituals
or things that people say well what are
you seeking from their are you making
any prayers are you doing anything now
that go along with this or uh I think a
lot of people will sort of
when they run into these sorts of
problems in their own life because if
you're taking psychedelics it's for a
purpose in you know for the first uh
you're you're looking to get something
out of it and what are people looking to
get out of usually meaning and purpose
usually people are at uh either it's
it's Hedonism and you're just wanting to
party in which case if you take enough
psychedelics you'll start to realize
that this is not a party drug at all
yeah this is a uh I I use the term
spiritual Loosely because it's not
really true spirituality but it is a
sort of a tool to tap into what we would
call the Unseen it is something so it
goes back to the story and I'm saying
right they were trying this is what he
was telling you right right and there's
no consistency really of practice
between these groups and uh I'm of the
belief that you know that we human
beings do not really have knowledge of
of the Unseen and we many of the groups
that are practicing these sorts of
things are sort of break-offs from very
ancient practices that they don't really
know what they're doing they're playing
with some very dangerous very dangerous
very dangerous sorts of things and
listen yeah because um I mean if you
want to know about the Unseen World open
up the Quran right right or the uh Islam
is laid out clear right right how to
protect yourself exactly from the Devils
the demons the shadeen and all these
other parts of the Unseen World but now
you're over here having a free-for-all
and playing with it you're literally big
trouble man there's a popular quote from
uh Carl Jung he said uh Beware of uh uh
unearned knowledge and I think that's a
lot of what you know you get these uh
that was one of the McKenna brothers
that said that you pick up the phone a
psychedelic is like picking up the phone
and they of course described it as God
but of course you're not contacting God
on the other side of that dude you're
contacting an unseen realm and you don't
know what entity that could be so uh but
there's this overflow of of sort of uh
unseen uh things that that are very
otherworldly and very unique and having
these experiences definitely shatters
the materialist conception of reality
and I think that's what a lot of people
end up doing that they have never
experienced any sort of legitimate
spirituality in their lives and then
they fall into this whole psychedelic
rabbit hole and they say this is you
know this is absolutely legitimate
spirituality but I think a consistent
practice over time would show that there
is no sort of community or consensus
that can be built out of these things
because it's such an individual process
and such an individual Endeavor that
truth has to be something that many
people can come to and because of its
very individualistic nature psychedelics
are not something that you can build
anything real out of so how do you get
exposure now to Islam in the midst of
all this right right and you said
earlier when we spoke that you had
looked into all the different religions
right right so the and what was it about
Islam that stood out from all of the
what we'd say clear our man-made
religions right right how did that and I
it's to me I mean it's not it's pretty
easy to recognize the truth right
amongst all these other man-made
religion but what was it with you that
had you even come to exploring Islam how
did you get to that point well I think
that's where the concept of fitra
becomes very important that if you are
connected to your natural disposition
then you sort of had this inclination to
seek truth and when you are met with
falsehood you can have a sort of
critical eye and and set it to the side
and say you know this may have some
aspect of of Truth or legitimate
spirituality within it but this is not
the capital T truth and um
I think what a lot of people will do in
the west is seek guidance from their own
traditional institutions we Muslims of a
small minority in the west you know less
than one percent so when you're
Westerner seeking advice from your
traditional religious institutions
you're going to go to the
judeo-christian tradition and because of
the incoherence and the
sort of degradation of that tradition
people are often left disenchanted and
they project that disenchantment to all
sort of traditional forms of religion
and because of Islam's one Islam's
incompatibility with all forms of
liberalism and also it's uh counter it's
it's sort of countering nature to
Judaism and Christianity people
instantly go to the Far East and you
know sort of seek Enlightenment from the
Far East and this is where you get met
with Buddhism and taoism and certain
forms of yoga and
this is where we spoke about modernism
and this idea that Divinity is within
everything including myself and I don't
think
often people are not really aware of the
the consequences of having a belief like
that that when you sort of adopt this
idea of monetism that it becomes very
difficult to
um
submit yourself to an external regular
practice or an external being and it
ends up being an amalgamation of
different contradictory religious
practices that become representative of
the individual ego yeah for people who
haven't heard this term monism you tell
them all that person has a part of God
in themselves right they have a part of
divinity right and this is sort of uh
very appealing to the Western mindset
that's been so isolated and so cut off
from
every sort of aspect of spirituality not
just the people in the society around
them but also the natural world so when
you come into contact with something
like modism from the Eastern spiritual
Traditions it's like a over correction
it's a religious over correction
overflow of spirituality that can again
be very appealing but
if taken to its logical extreme it ends
up being a sort of self-worship and it
was Imam al-ghazali that said the worst
form of shirk was worship of the self
and I think that's what a lot of people
have fallen into I think that's to get
back to the whole liberalism and uh the
new age wokeism political correctness
movement that's exactly what all this is
just more in a political realm as
opposed to a spiritual realm people work
for yourself worship yes worshiping the
desires you can see how far people can
go right right I mean that's in the
Quran as well have you seen the one who
takes their desires as their God yeah
besides Allah so then how was your what
was your when was your first exposure to
Islam was it from a book was it from uh
from a friend from a Muslim yeah um I
had read the Quran earlier in life as I
read pretty much all of I read the Pali
Canon and Buddhism The Vedas the Bible
everything but I was reading all these
things not really with the sort of deep
understanding just sort of getting
through all of them so that I can have a
little bit under my belt and it wasn't
until later when the spiritual
experiences all started to play in One
Direction and um
uh it was the Quran
um the the the writings of the Islamic
elements that I was Finding in a lot of
other literature as well as uh people
like Imam al-ghazali um Rene guanon was
another big one as well with his sort of
traditionalism uh
it's um
anyone again anyone who sort of follows
that fitra and is honest with themselves
about about not what they want
spirituality to be or not what they want
truth to be but what it truly is for
itself will be led to Islam inshallah
yeah so now you you have some exposure
to Islam you start reading you you read
the Quran you said before was it it was
um English translation was a good
English translation did it stick with
you what you read before and then what
happened that because you recently it's
not too long ago it's been how long now
about a year I took my shahada in um
November of last year last year 2022
close to a year this was my first
Ramadan and I was uh I was praying about
six to eight months before my shahada I
was very reluctant to accept many of
these things because of my sort of
background I knew it would be a big
social change it was a big diversion
from a lot of the things that I had
previously thought but um again he reads
if
the the you know when Allah speaks about
the Hypocrites it it is certainly
um not something you want to be and when
that resonates with you when you know I
am a hypocrite because I know this to be
true and I have not accepted it in a
public sense it can become very
um internally conflicting so what
convinced you that Islam was indeed the
Quran was from the Creator right and
that Prophet Muhammad was indeed a
messenger sent by the Creator and peace
be upon him is that you actually ended
up accepting Islam it was uh ultimately
the Quran and the Syria literature that
I think was the sort of final Tipping
Point
um I had never actually met a Muslim
before taking my shahada never nope
never met a Muslim
um and uh I'm not one to uh dip a toe
and these sorts of things I take it very
seriously so alhamdulillah I think Allah
every day for opening my heart to the
truth and for guiding me to the truth
and also allowing me to have a sort of
experiential and rational Foundation
from which I think true faith be built
upon yeah you remind me of the the
Russell Brand like a a younger version
It's the hair it's the hair and it's uh
he covers a lot of different good topics
uh he's somebody we've seen him one time
with the Quran but for someone like you
who has also he seems like he went down
that route hippie yeah the new age new
age and whatnot but uh you can see the
difference if somebody's insincere they
really want to know the truth uh you you
come to Islam like you did we want the
best for him also this is Russell
Russell Brand
um he also um does what you did I mean I
interview a lot of people and then I see
at one point they get to a point where
okay they're seeking the truth but they
have to there's a very um powerful
Hadith where Prophet Muhammad is it's
Hadith where Allah is saying yeah all my
slaves are misguided unless I guide them
so ask me of my guidance so the Creator
is saying ask me if my guidance many
people are not asking at what point do
you see that you stop that you asked how
did you ask
for guidance I think the entirety of my
religious or my spiritual journey was in
in asking it was a deep yearning for
truth
I just think you have to shed you're
sort of preconceived biases and your
preconceived notions of what you think
is true before you're able to do that
that Allah will put these things in
front of you and it will be a test you
know are you going to accept this you
know it to be true in your heart but but
are you going to submit to that external
practice are you going to submit to you
know putting your head on the floor five
times a day you know it's uh I think
that can be very difficult Malcolm X
spoke about this in his autobiography
that could be a very difficult thing for
the very
egoistic culture of the West that we
have such a sort of infatuation with
ourselves that it becomes very difficult
to lose that and that's truly we speak
often about Freedom that's where true
freedom and Liberation is found it's we
as human beings are inherently
faith-based creatures we don't know
enough about the world around us or
about ourselves to to operate without a
belief in something so do you feel you
can save people a lot of trouble where
they don't have to go to the farm there
experimenting like you did they don't
have to go through all of these books
and everything I mean it's like someone
who took a journey and someone it took
that person years to get to a
destination right as opposed to someone
else here's the map I can get you there
and have or not even a quarter of the
time right so what would you say to
somebody who's thinking about
experimenting with the toad right
somebody who's uh thinking about you
know going to a different part of the
world to go join a Buddhist or seminary
or whatnot you've experimented you've
looked into all these things how do they
know that's not the way how do they know
that's not the truth I would definitely
import implore people to seek the truth
for themselves but uh you have to be
willing to you have to know that the
truth has consequences and um I like
Omar suleiman's language on this he
calls it the Allure of narcissistic
spirituality uh that that if you view
religion as a sort of if you approach
religion in a way that could just
benefit your life in a worldly sense
then you're not actually seeking truth
in a genuine sort of way that you have
to uh drop all your all your previous
Notions of what you think truth may be
be willing to come to the truth and
whatever consequences it may have in
your own personal life and be be genuine
with the Creator
[Music]
and tell me have you
were you experimenting all at all we you
talked about earlier okay going back to
some of the religions because many of
these are about self-worship but someone
would say no when you have Christianity
Judaism these would be about worshiping
one God but then you have over here
certain attributes that are assigned to
God that will go against the pure
monotheism in one of them the other one
is about Trinity God dying for your sins
how did you tackle and wrestle with that
well I would also implore people to look
into the historical sources here as well
I think in Islam we happen to love the
the preservation of the tradition is
something that really
shines as unique when you get into the
sort of historical uh study of the
religions in something like Christianity
uh it's it's very clear I think after
the 19th century and 20th Century study
of Christians themselves went into the
Dead Sea Scrolls and all these sorts of
discoveries that have shown us that
whatever original Christianity was and
of course Muslims we believe is Islam
whatever original Christianity was it's
not being practiced anymore the the
entirety of the tradition we have from
Eastern Orthodoxy for example would be
from from the Council of nicaea on this
is around like 350 A.D so this is
hundreds of years after the the life of
Issa and
um
uh you even have the logical
incoherencies with things like the
Trinity and I don't want to trivialize
the the Christian position of the
Trinity I think it's a lot more nuanced
than what maybe even a lot of Muslims
would give Credence to but it certainly
you have to twist yourself into a
pretzel to try and explain that to
somebody whereas we have Concepts like
taheed which sort of dispel a lot of the
falsehoods that uh the Simplicity of uh
of of one God the Oneness of Allah and
the explanation of the duality of the
you know the mind-body dichotomy
experience that human beings have that
the same sort of dualities experience
with Allah we believe that the Creator
is outside of the creation but that
certain uh elements permeate within the
creation like his Mercy like his Divine
will like his love and um
that sort of same parallel happens with
our mind body system there's a clear
overlap with this so again if you're
exploring truth in a genuine sort of way
you would see a lot of these sorts of uh
incoherencies within other Traditions as
well as some of the things that they
have in common with Islam that from an
Islamic perspective this would be
because they were once previous to the
the prophethood of Muhammad
these would actually be Islam in in a
genuine sense in that it was only
through cultural manipulation that they
were
manipulated and changed over time do you
feel that now Christians as we're seeing
they're getting fed up
and people of
who fear God who love God and they're
saying that their Church their synagogue
they're seeing the compromises that are
happening right right and now even such
people as the pope and other religious
figures are now bending and saying
certain things are acceptable right but
the book says is not acceptable right so
claiming to be a representative of God
but then crushing going against the
Commandments of God and the Christians
are seeing that but then do you think if
and many now they'll go and say and you
say you've even had so many islamophobes
and whatnot say it looks like I have to
I might even give Islam a shot now right
right but and because Islam doesn't Bend
because it is indeed from the creator of
the heavens and the Earth right and then
many Christians are saying that this is
when they look into it this is actually
going like what you said the natural
inclination the fitra it fits with it
so are you saying that now this will be
a for Christians watching and other
people God fearing people people who say
I love God that this would be more in
tune
with their belief on the situation at
hand what's happening with the
sexualization of children right right
and you know the chopping off of a good
healthy body partition yeah absolutely
yeah I think um the uh sort of the fact
that the Christian tradition has now
devolved and sort of degradated to the
point that today is representative of it
being a false sort of uh
man-made religion
um we can even see in the the fact of
sectarianism that uh alhamdulillah Islam
has not Fallen victim to the sort of
sectarianism and we actually have a a
deep Hadith tradition about we are
anti-sectarian that we try our best to
to not differ amongst ourselves and even
the the smaller disputes we will have we
agree on the basic Doctrine we know
we're all Muslims you can go to any
mosque in the world and you can pray
next to a brother and whatever little
differences there will be it will not be
apparent to you especially to the
layperson as opposed to Christianity
where you have a multitude of different
sex and they believe it's deep
theological differences between them and
I also think to address Judaism for a
second there's a
an issue with the ethnocentric nature of
Judaism that its smaller numbers uh
there's there's less Jews that can get
outside of that Branch because it
becomes very difficult to escape being a
Jew when it's seen as an ethnic identity
it's not just a religious label
um as opposed to Christianity where it's
a little bit more abstract it's a little
bit more universalized and there's a
deep theological tradition that uh I
think leads one to sort of end up
with the sectarian divide so in closing
now what finally okay you realize okay
the Quran is from the Creator you've
done your homework was it difficult was
it difficult I mean you talk a little
bit The Challenge now suppressing your
desires right conditioned over years to
follow your desires and right all of
this monism and there's a piece of God
in you you got to submit to God all this
stuff how did you overcome that that you
finally were like was the truth that
powerful were you just at a point in
your life that you're like I got to do
this this is the truth I mean right and
and
tell me what was God always there in
your life was there a Creator because
when you say God for many people you
know God can be like yourself you think
you're extracted abstract you know it's
something like if the man in the clouds
with long beards some people think you
know this is God and they run away from
this because his concept doesn't make
sense but when you finally understood
the tohi the pure monotheism
that is Islam clearly Loosely defines
who the Creator is you are
because many people get to that point
but because so many external influences
family because of they're going to be
judged they feel the pressure they're
like I'm not having it what was your
state of mind at the time
um I think on an individual personal
level the truth was very powerful for me
and alhamdulillah I think it was a a bit
easier for me to submit to those things
after just doing so much research and
just getting so far into the weeds with
it
um but I think in even more important
aspect is the community that once you
take your shahada and you see the love
that your fellow Muslims have for you
and you go to the mosque every day and
you see the the the the continuity that
that the Muslims have with one another
it becomes a lot easier you know even if
you have sort of previous friends and
family that can
it can be very difficult to deal with
consequences of something like a
conversion you always will have your
community to to be there behind you and
to seek refuge in Allah I mean there's
there's no sweeter feeling than being
able to put your head on a mat for being
able to put your head on the ground for
you know 17 times a day at these
different just the
obligatory prayers it's uh once you
start to do that I think I would also
implore a lot of people to explore the
spiritual practices even before if you
feel very reluctant to openly try to
explore these things in the actual
masjids themselves
do it at home you know make do a ask
Allah and say Allah's name uh you know
ask for guidance ask for help put your
head on the ground also something that I
think is a big to speak to the whole uh
I I grew up very secular so I had this
very abstract notion of God and God was
never really in my life previously but
even when I did sort of adopt this whole
spiritual uh transcendental awareness
it was in a very natural sense not
natural that that you want to look to
things like the the goddess of nature
and you want to look to the the Earth
and worship those sorts of things which
again like we spoke about earlier is a
form of self-worship because you are
part of that natural world you're part
of the creation
but um
I think if you look at things like solo
we'll do fasting
um I've heard it said that the uh the
Muslim is the only uh person on Earth
that worships in the way that the
primordial man worships and I would
think that's absolutely true that if you
truly are someone who wants to be in
tune with the natural rhythms of Nature
and wants to be in tune with the
universal law it would be through uh you
know these practices that we have in the
celestial bodies that determine their
times that our our prayer times change
based on where the sun is and and our
fasting based on the lunar calendar and
where Ramadan is this following the
Sunnah is what actually allows you to be
in tune with the natural world around
you before we conclude so
yeah I hear all of this um
many times in in the years that I've had
so many different interviews and it it
all comes down to a person being sincere
and I want the audience who's listening
because people the the satanic forces of
the Unseen World the confusion the
conditioning from society
condition someone like you were in your
early life
and here comes Islam it's so simple easy
to understand you have a book now
revealed over 23 years of Quran
memorized by millions and and one of the
I know you're fairly new were you able
to now start praying in the Arabic and
to start yes yes so I I might put you on
the spot here but for a purpose of
people seeing like
to put the rest maybe a myth that's out
there oh it's revealed in Arabic it's
one of the Miracles of it now and that
people like you someone who's up from a
from a background
that you're not Arab
you don't have any air blood right but
if you were living during time of Jesus
you'd be speaking Aramaic and reciting
this in Aramaic but now the Quran you're
praying and then now you also know the
meaning but this is something that is a
living miracle and if you can go ahead
and recite the opening chapter for us of
the al-fatiha and so people can hear
this
and from there you'll give the Meaning
go ahead
foreign
[Music]
this is a miracle I wanted people to
hear it to go ahead and experience it so
obviously this is a call this is in
there
the meaning of you're praising the
creator of the heavens and the Earth
um
you are calling uh alhamdulillah praises
to Allah and the Lord Lord of all the
worlds Master of the Judgment you alone
we worship you alone we seek for help
guide us to the straight path the path
of those you favor not the PO those who
are in your anger go astray so anyone
now who's out there confused they can
even make this prayer to God right
that's right
inshallah so uh this is truly amazing
it's really amazing uh uh hopefully
inshallah this can be a benefit for so
many millions of people are out there
who are confused we get them unconfused
they can experience some of your
experiences uh and they can go ahead and
come to uh the path that's brought you
what has it brought you at the end what
what would you say you've gotten from
inner peace inner peace inner peace see
I didn't want to say it I wanted I was
going to say I know I know what you're
going to say right right right this
sense of belonging belonging in your
case purpose purpose absolutely these
are all the things that you're seeking
if you're truly seeking a spiritual
resolve it's uh yeah it's a blessing I
think Allah every day for guiding me to
the truth and making me a Muslim menai I
I ask that he guides all of uh all of
those seeking Truth uh as well I mean
thank you Alex Abdullah thank you for
sharing your story with us
not leave without giving you a gift if
you are not yet Muslim and you tune in
to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
alhamdulillah brothers and sisters as
you can see we've acquired the property
and we're getting right to work and with
your duas and support we can go ahead
and get the Masjid and meghadawa Center
up open and running in sha Allah imagine
every person that prays here gets
educated and guided to Islam here you'll
get a part of all those blessings and
rewards insha Allah what are you waiting
for brothers and sisters you're going to
leave it all behind anyway so go ahead
and in Dustin you're Hereafter that's
Everlasting click the link below donate
right now reward all of you
foreign
[Music]